you know jake paul doing his thing right
now a few years ago y'all supposed to
fight way before he fought anybody
yeah would you revisit that situation
uh knowing you see him knocked out nate
robinson
knocked out dude uh ben alaska whatever
his name is would you
get in the ring with jake paul today
today i mean like i still want to fight
i'll fight anybody i fight whoever like
i don't care but like right now i'm
focused on my music right right i feel
like i had a lot of fight offs and [ __ ]
like that you know you know you were
supposed to weren't you supposed to
fight chris brown and got cancelled he
cancelled
he backed out of it right yeah but yeah
but the jake paul thing is like
we we i'm gonna be honest with you we
need a black man to knock him out
because nate robertson made us look bad
so we we need a black king to get in the
ring with him
are you that are you the answer to that
yeah for sure i'm not the [ __ ]
how much money do i need to put on that
one just tell me right now right like a
honeycomb
i ain't gonna put it that much i got two
games you know
however much like jake paul is gonna be
favored to win so if you bet on him
you're gonna get
way better pay out mm-hmm because you
know he's a bad boy low-key now he
he i i mean i don't know like right
like we just going off what we see and
it's like you gotta you can't believe
half the [ __ ] you see but i was y'all
was first he was training everything for
that fight when it was going down huh
who
was jake paul like four years ago five
years ago
oh yeah i would train yeah i mean it was
cool like we was ready we were gonna do
it but you know i had i got
it i got locked up and [ __ ] right right
it's all good like i ain't tripping like
i'm really focused on my music though
like i'm really focused on she making
clout the music video on my record label
i feel like that type of [ __ ] was just
like entertaining
also by the way another trendy set
fighting jake paul
he was supposed to be the guy to fight
jake paul and now look what's going on
i think you're the reason jay paul
popping in the in the uh boxing scene
right now that's the fact i put jake
paul alone in the fight but
we ain't gonna say that what we gonna
say is [ __ ] jake paul he was fighting
what's the [ __ ] kfc
kfi what's [ __ ] knight ksi ksi i was
told kf to be here he will fight him
before the whole
thing so he been doing his boxing thing
so we're gonna give him no that was his
brother
his brother fought him oh wow he's about
his little brother
but more the story we all look the same
white people i mean nah
they're just two brothers and i tied one
of them [ __ ] up in the music video
logan paul a long time ago oh you tied
him up in the video oh that's cool yeah
yeah with my wrist i put all them things
on look lord stop more so
short the difference is that
i've been starting to fight and [ __ ]
back then when back then all the way
back then
when he was just youtube blogging and of
course i'm the one who started the
celebrity fight
i'm aware i believe it i really yeah man
there was a few that you were supposed
to be a part of that i was really
looking forward to i was like damn